the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
so today's development I'm going to be
go infancy towards adulthood
next Thursday we'll talk about
development after infancy to adulthood
and over age
and it's amazing think about babies and
how do they get going and how two
scientists discover from babies and
young children how their minds are
fundamentally different than adults and
how your mind was fundamentally
different than it is as an adult and so
and then the last thing will be a
dangerous experiment where my wife will
come over with my two-year-old in my
four-year-old and we'll try to do a
developmental demonstration in front of
you but I should warn you that live
children uh have their own will so we'll
see how that goes okay all right so one
thing that people are struck by babies
is that babies are cute okay and it's
not just it's not yeah it is thought to
be not just fun but kind of maybe a
really important biological thing we
talked about motherese before
singsong talked to babies that helped
them to learn language there's something
about adults finding babies cute that
makes them want to help babies okay
parents and Friends I mean the cuteness
is thought to be kind of an evolutionary
you know reward for dealing with a baby
so and then people have said well what
is it it's a little bit different about
a baby's face than an adult they have
rounder heads they have foreheads that
protrude more towards their sloped back
more they have larger eyes
proportionately smaller jaw bones
proportionally and people use the term
neoteny to describe this kind of infant
proportions or properties of faces which
are universal and of course a lot of
people discover this in advertising or
cartoons and so here's an interesting
example of how Mickey Mouse has over the
years from the original version of
Mickey Mouse to the current super cute
super tested super Disney a version of
Mickey Mouse has become increasingly neo
tonight and how much the cartoonists
literally know that or just have kept
saying you know what makes a cuter and
cuter and cuter and ended up with a lot
of the same proportions in Mickey
else's face that make infants so cute
and desirable you know we don't really
know but but the world kind of feels
this even adult research is a little
funny line of research that says adults
who look more baby-faced okay get
treated a little bit different socially
so I so here's a Leonardo DiCaprio and
baby-faced adults and experiments are
perceived as just by their faces as more
naive more honest more helpless more
kind more warm and more you know just
people think this is going to be a nice
warm person okay guessing from faces
they're using the cues of neoteny other
studies have found that people who are
baby-faced are statistically more likely
to be found innocent in cases of
intentional wrongdoing okay so the
whether whether they're trying to prove
that somebody on purpose try to do
something bad you go not that cute
little person right but there's no
difference if it's if it's cases
involved negligence something we should
have didn't something because we know
babies aren't super responsible for how
they behave right okay so it's kind of
like defense on the on the on the and
they're less likely to receive votes in
elections okay so people we have won't
even tell you this but people have done
all kinds of analyses of faces that win
elections in the US and around the world
and there's two dimensions that people
look for what looks like somebody's
empathetic and what looks like
somebody's competent alright so you want
babies when it's fun but when you have
to figure out how to balance the budget
you know that doesn't seem like a baby
task all right so it's kind of funny uh
you know a lot of voters you know go by
instinct as well as by sort of facts or
stated values so in the development of
infants into into adults the classic
debates about how our mind grasps the
world have played out yet again in a
powerful way
you know the nature nurture debate
what's in our genes and gets us going
what's acquired from the environment
philosophers is that knowledge starts
with innate or genetic or more evolved
capacities other ones who've emphasized
that we pick it up from the world
empirically as measuring scientists
serving so for example Aristotle wrote
that nothing in the there's nothing in
the
select which was not first in the census
that's the empirical view right it's out
there in the world and you solve it and
starting with a blank slate and in fact
the behaviorists of course we're
believed in this with a vengeance in
psychology so Watson row give me a dozen
healthy infants well-formed and my own
specified world to bring them up and
I'll guarantee to take any of them one
at random and train him to become any
type of specialist I might select a
doctor lawyer artist merchant chief and
yes even beggarman and thief that it's
all the environment and a blank slate
and who really knows but infants are
born with some incredible things we'll
talk about them today one of them is
this experiment from Andy meltzoff
which is this that it seems like within
moments of birth infants are equipped
with a desire to imitate adults a desire
to imitate right and why people have
been really impressed by this is if you
have that in your genes and in your
nature it's a good way to learn about
the world is to imitate people you see
around you right it's kind of a driving
principle I'll imitate their language
their social mores right okay so here's
what here's what meltzoff did sticks out
his tongue opens his mouth
purses his lips and here's the infant
one day old or a couple days old tongue
out mouth open lips pursed okay now I
should warn you about one thing these
are the greatest hits' pieces of that
research people debate about how
perfectly this happens all right so I
was frustrated with my infant came home
and I did all the stuff and she would
not instantly do everything she was
supposed to do all right it's a
statistical thing because you know when
you see these pictures they're showing
you the best moments they have to defend
that it happens above chance
statistically but it's not like every
expression you make they copy you okay
and that's why there's still some debate
about exactly what's going on but they
definitely on average imitate an adult
within a day or two of birth for
completely arbitrary as far as we think
expressions so it's a very powerful
mechanism for learning that appears to
be in place because there's two ways we
could imagine right genetically
programmed learning one is that you know
the content of it already but in other
ways that you just have stuff that makes
you a learner right
so being an imitator is a general way to
make you a learner without being very
specific to the content so we talked a
little bit about this already but you
know psychologists are unbelievably
brilliant I think I'm really blown away
about how they can figure out what an
infant knows and doesn't know or a young
child knows or doesn't know and they do
this indirectly by things like looking
time and well you've seen this I'll give
you an example or two and you'll see
some more examples as a measure of what
the baby knows or the young child knows
and of course if they look longer at
something it could be because they
prefer it and also if it's a base on a
memory task something like you saw
something you see it again that would
tell you there's some sort of
discrimination they can tell things
apart based on memory and then sometimes
people will push this memory thing with
habituation or familiarize ation so if
you show something to a baby over and
over and over again they get sort of
tired of it and at that moment they'll
change the stimulus and they'll see
whether the baby gets newly attentive
now if it's something that the baby
doesn't grasp they won't get newly
attentive you know nothing's changed in
their mind if it's something the baby
understands then you know they'll say
wow something interesting is happening
and they'll look longer so here's an
example of you know baby
getting bored because they're showing
something over and over and something
new okay that's the kind of things that
people measure and they you know we're
doing it loosely here they measure it
pretty carefully I should tell you the
people who do this kind of research
they'll film it they'll show two
unbiased people like you may be judges
okay to say how long is the baby looking
where is looking you don't know where
the what the babies should be looking at
or not so researchers take care to make
it not just you know that you're
convinced in your heart of hearts
they're looking more they film it they
show to people who don't know what's
going on they try to make it a blind
procedure in many ways the better
research so how do we know things so
even a very young infants look
selectively at novel objects if
something's new even at one day if you
show them checker boards with different
sized squares same size same size same
size wait a couple of seconds smaller
squares they look more that shows you
they saw the difference in the squares
they even remember somehow in their mind
the difference between the squares
because when you switch it
start looking more something interesting
has happened based on perception and
memory another thing that we've
mentioned I'll just remind you is that
infants are almost from birth seem to
love to control or provoke their
environment so we already mentioned to
you that 20 months old prefer a mobile
that responds to their bodily movements
they like things that they control if
they take a two-month-old and they put a
string on their wrist by which they can
control a showing of Sesame Street you
know they kind of like that and if you
stops tesa me seat they can show anger
on their face hey you know I was in
charge here who has a remote control now
right and four and five months old a
little bit older I remain angry when the
video comes back on because that's not
what they wanted they wanted to control
the presentation of the video right so
infants said this apparent craving and
to explore and feel like they have some
control over their environment at an age
when they don't control a lot because of
their limited physical capacity in the
first three or four months infants
explore the world a lot by their mouths
that's what people worry about to not
leave around things like that they will
put into their mouth and swallow that
are dangerous okay because their visual
and auditory systems and their system
with their hand are slowly developing by
five or six months around the world they
start to explore with their hands and
their eyes around them as their motor
system gets more mature as your visual
system gets great gains acuity and we
already know that infants use social
cues to guide exploration one of the big
changes has happened in the last ten
years I'd say in infant studies or child
studies has been a lot of appreciation
about the intersection between cognition
and social interaction there used to be
like two different worlds the people who
studied language you know they would
have algorithms and formulas about the
language and then the social people who
studied how babies were cute or
something right but there's been more
and more thought that a deep thing in us
that helps cognition grow is the social
relations that an infant is drawn to
parents and caretakers so for example a
six-month-old if their mother let's say
roles or pounds a ball they tend to copy
that in to imitate that action they
follow the eyes of a person joint
attention you know the windows the eyes
are the windows on the soul we know eyes
mean a lot where are people putting
their ten
what are they paying attention to
infants pick up on this very early on
and they if somebody looks over there
they look over there if you look at them
they know that your attention is focused
on them and sometimes people will say
you know because psychologists left to
test everything is it just the way the
head is turning so if you put a you know
cover somebody's head
they don't follow it anymore they know
it has to be the eyes you know
reflecting where the mind is putting his
attention all right it's not the head
direction it's the eyes here's something
infants who are a little bit better at
following eyes either maturing faster or
something also learn language faster
they get words faster and syntax faster
it's as if part of that social
interaction is helping to drive the
language learning so that's how these
social things and language things
interact very substantially and we
already said that a 12 month old will
stop at a visual cliff but if the mother
smiles there they go okay so constant
learning that mixes in the cognitive and
the social now the epic name in
developmental psychology is Jean Piaget
because prior to him roughly speaking in
the science of child development people
just thought children were sort of
boring and dumb okay yeah it's like like
they need a lot of attention you know
please you know finish MIT so we can
talk with you intelligently okay all
right so so just people were not that
interested you know partly as the world
was different in so many ways
there was no practically no formal
psychology experimentation or thought
about what really children's mental
lives were like and Piaget I have a
wrong year there 1886 developed the Kahn
he himself was a child prodigy trained
in biology very early interesting
weather categories are in her heads or
in the world tried poetry worked with
Binet on intelligence testing became
interested in patterns of errors than
successes you'll see that in many ways
what he discovered about how a child
mind is different than yours
fundamentally is based on the patterns
of their errors and he said there's two
basic things going on it's a huge idea
one is a simulation that you incorporate
new knowledge into existing cognitive
structures it's basically ways you think
about the world and new knowledge is
added that's important but he thought
the dramatic thing that happens in
infancy and childhood is what he call
adaptation that the fundamental ways in
which you understand the world are
shifted through development to
accommodate new evidence so there's a
wonderful book if you come across they
called the scientist in the crib okay
but it's kind of a pun it's written by
scientists to study infants but the idea
is that in a sense every infant is kind
of his or her own scientist as you were
probing the world and discovering the
physical and social laws of the world
okay because they don't know them coming
in and they're going to pick up a lot of
them
and they're going to probe them you know
but fail to publish the results okay so
so he postulated that there was these
big stages what he called the
sensorimotor age zero to two where the
world is one of what you see and the
physical actions and there's not much
representation of ideas or lasting
thoughts and we'll see some examples of
these between two and seven you start to
be able to keep a thought in your mind
you still have an egocentric perspective
you see the world from your view but not
appreciating the views of somebody else
you start to use language a lot of
flimsy a discussion about fantasy and
reality I can tell you with my own
daughter who you will meet she's still
working out whether fairies really exist
or not okay and this was chaotic as we
went to some skating show where there
was a where Tinkerbell was a human
dancing and that totally made this
situation very complicated right cuz you
could tell a car okay alright so she's
still working on that concrete you know
as you get seven to eleven organized
logical thought still concrete as
opposed to sort of abstract and then you
move to more adult-like
cognition which we'll talk about next
week so the idea is from birth to two
years you know you would love to have an
infinite just tell you what do I think
the world is really like they have very
modest language of course right so they
can't tell you what they see so the
thought is they have fleeting
disconnected sensory impressions and
motor reactions it's all at what do I
see how am i responding that that their
focus of thought is centered on actions
not things or intentions and I'll show
you that in a very concrete way there's
no distinction there in mind between
things that are stable in the world and
transient events no distinction between
themselves and the world around them
it's all just one big sort of mush until
they get to some more
they can have abstract representations
that separate these things out so so
let's talk about object permanence that
so I'm going to show you that you have
object permanence just simply by saying
here's my pointer I need a volunteer
this is so easy that you will not feel
scared I prom is it all right thank you
very much so
you see this where do you think it is
now okay yeah if I was a really cool
teacher who did magic you know it would
be gone all right so uh but yes and you
know it's there that's object permanence
okay all right if you can if you turn
your head you believe it's probably
still there okay but now knowing that's
going beyond the fundamentals of
perception that's your knowledge and
representing in your head there's
something I don't see but I know it's
there that is not available to a zero to
two-year-old so for example if they see
a rattle they feel a rattle but now if
you if they look away or if you just put
a sheet of paper in front of it I'll
show you a couple of examples they
behave as if the rattle no longer exists
just like I did in front of you if you
just cover it up it's gone as if it
doesn't exist because their mind cannot
represent what they do not see right in
front of them so out of sight out of
existence so you can show them a toy
they love and until about eight months
once you could do this and they go they
start crying a protest but they won't
reach for it even when it's easily
within the reach out of sight out of
mind it doesn't exist they can't
represent in their mind what they don't
see and then there's another one out
you'll see I'll show you'll see a film
of this but let me tell you this is this
shows you about actions versus other
things so imagine you hide a toy under
one location the child searches there
finds it you hide it again in the same
location you know you encourage a child
to search they find it they do it two or
three times now in front of the child
you take that same object that you've
shown them like this several times it
grabbed several times and you simply in
front of them pick it up and put it over
here and they're viewing everything in
full view just like you did okay
what do they do when it's there champ
turn to grab they grab here the wrong
place the place where they grab before
because what's in their mind is the
action they did not the object as an
independent thing they can put in their
mind as that makes answer and I'll show
you I'll show you several pieces of this
so it's called the aid not be effect I
put this eh-eh-eh-eh in the front full
of you put it over here and they reach
over here to get it so this is this idea
that they're in their head is not the
toy their head is representing the thing
on the right that reached for because
they don't represent ideas of things
they represent actions that they've done
so here's object permanence here's a
child you know sees a toy they like you
put up in front of them this thing and
tragically it's disappeared okay it's
gone out of existence in the world and
some people have done some sort of niors
imaging suggesting the kids who sort of
get past the stage are developing some
frontal maturation but I think the most
compelling things are the videos or the
kids themselves
so let me show you another film again
very cleverly that Rene buyer Jean has
been one of the leaders in this field
very cleverly showing you what infants
are grasp and don't grasp
not only the brilliance of these
experiments I mean really but you know
these infants are really trying to
figure out the world and coming up with
hypotheses that you know they're
confirming and then when they're broken
down right there they're upset what's
going on so let's move on to age two to
seven especially in the early years of a
pre operational stage and one of the
coolest things I will try this and see
how it goes with with with some girls in
a few minutes is this idea so if you see
two glasses filled with equal amounts of
liquid and you pour one over into the
thinner taller glass see which will have
more water in it a or C the same all
right thank you okay but not if your
two-year-old or a four-year-old so it's
called conservation of liquid
so it's kind of fascinating isn't that
it's kind of amazing and you know it's
all if you do this with a three-year-old
Garrett is virtually guaranteed building
this I mean all of you did it all over
the world and in some sense as far as
you can guess you know all throughout
our species history so brilliant ways of
showing the babies and or young children
really see a little bit of a different
world you know that than you and I do
okay as adults so conversation of it so
here's another really uh I think you
know very powerful area of research
which is taking perspectives from the
view that other people have thoughts and
feelings besides yourself and how you
interact with them so so this is and
people call this idea theory of mind the
idea that you understand that other
people out there have their own thoughts
their own feelings distinct from yours
and in the most challenging case they
can even be false beliefs you could
personally have wrong information in
their head and truly believe it even
when you know it's wrong because you as
an adult realize that thoughts are one
thing and sort of physical reality is
another thing all right but that's not
what children think they think is
there's just one reality that's why at
the very youngest stage they think if
they cover their eyes right that you
don't know where they are because they
think there's one physical reality only
and they're you know they don't realize
it's another perspective besides their
own so here's a very clever experiment
showing you that at three months
children code the word in terms of
actions and by six to nine month they
begin to understand intentions that
people out there animals too but we'll
just focus on people have intentions and
goals in their head so here's what the
experiment they do using this
habituation a person there's a two
pedestals here and a person reaches
again and again for a ball so now what
do you believe the intention is to reach
for the ball okay you see it ten times
the babies losing interest
now comes their shocker right to get the
baby crying or laughing or drooling get
the baby's attention that you can
measure by how they respond and in some
conditions
you know something goes down and when it
goes back up the person reaches but now
they reach four they take the same
reach for the left pedestal but it's a
teddy bear or in another case they reach
for the ball and the opposite side who
depending on their age sees these two
different changes in the scenario as
startling the three-month olds are
startled when the person reaches for the
same object okay the three months old
because they're in their mind the only
thing that was really happening was
reached for the left reach for the left
reach for the left and now you're
reaching for the right the action
changed because the action is
independent of intention it's just what
happened what happened what happened and
they're shocked when the person goes for
the ball over here by six to nine month
they're shocked relatively speaking when
the person reaches for the same action
but now the goal is different grabbing
the teddy bear it's as if they
understand the intention of the person
was to get the ball and these children
think the only thing that's happening is
physical action physical action physical
action so a very clever experiment by
this habituation and looking time to
shoot it at three months all you see is
actions and by six and nine months you
start to grasp that people have
intentions in their head above and
beyond their actions that govern their
actions so to make it really sort of
tricky there's this very clever
experimental that makes then we'll try
it in a few minutes this way this
so-called sally-ann problem because it's
been so widely cited and discussed so
you sell you tell a child this story
imagine there's two girls here Sally or
Anne and Sally takes a ball and puts a
boat in this basket below and then she
leaves the room and who's a little bit
of a troublemaker takes the ball out of
here and puts it into this box and
closes the box here's the big question
when Sally comes back in and looks for
this ball where will she look and a
three-year-old says in the box now she
was out of the room there's no way for
her to look that's in the box but for
the three-year-old there's not thoughts
and reality there's just kind of reality
does that make sense the three-year-old
can't entertain the idea that sally has
in her head wrong knowledge of where
this ball is that she couldn't have
known
and she's going to act on the knowledge
that's in her head that's the content of
her mind the three old says there's one
reality the balls over here I know it
everybody knows that what else is there
to even think about that makes it but
the typical five-year-old will say you
know Sally will look in the wrong place
she'll look in the basket because that
I'm sure look yeah in the wrong place
where compared to where the ball is now
because she believes it's there she has
the wrong idea in her head that ideas
can be independent of physical
observable things in the world this is a
universal finding man I'm going to
change my settings sorry your handout
has this in practically every country
where this test is a three-year-olds
don't have a theory of mind
five-year-olds do turns out and you
could take it yes the older sibling you
have the younger you become getting a
good theory of mind
what's your get nobody really knows what
the answer is but what's your guests the
more siblings you have we're older than
you
the younger by some number of months
people tend to show that they have they
can understand that people have all
kinds of thoughts and beliefs in their
head what's your guess
yeah they were cured by their sibling so
no but but but on top of that the
intuition is and we don't really know
this is hard to brew you know they're
living in a world because they have
older siblings who do unkind things to
them who have superior powers over them
physically they're much more socially
you know have to figure out what's going
on to survive happily and make their way
in the world right you know that the big
five-year-old is like he or she is like
dominant you know and the two-year-old
is like trying to steer around like what
is that five-year-old think how will I
not get into trouble with that
five-year-old and my mother and my right
you know that a younger sibling is more
social pressures to figure out what's
going on and steer your way around and
not get in trouble with your older
siblings I'll just say welcome back to
autism I'll just say a word about this
now you hear a lot about it the current
guess is that it's approximately one out
of every 140 children a shocking
increase in numbers to what people
believed it was many years ago
mysteriously there's many more boys than
girls with autism estimates are four to
one or ten to one range all
it's hard to know for sure we'll talk
more about that but autism is defined by
three things a sort of weakness our
deficit in social interaction
children with autism have are adults a
difficulty in social interaction in
communication and they have lots of
repetitive behaviors that are can be
difficult to help interactions with
others and when people test theory of
mind and children with autism is
typically delayed by five or six years
on average for those children who can
take the test at all they have a very
slowly developing very delayed theory of
mind and understanding what's in the
content of the thoughts of other people
and that's considered one of those sort
of biggest challenges is how they relate
to other people understanding what the
other person's thinking and feeling okay
so just for a couple minutes I'm going
to show you a video then we're going to
try it so the biggest challenges to
Piaget
have been this idea that there's these
distinct stages of thought that your
mind shifts literally how its
constructed and understands the world
and that people have thought the process
is much more continuous than Piaget had
suggested and here's one compelling
example of that kind so this is the a
not be experiment there's a food to food
Wells and something of interest to this
infant the seven-month-old looks at the
toy here it gets covered up and in the
toy this is well this is sorry something
was placed in B & B B it's it's one of
the two wells he continues to look at B
when both are covered he knows the toys
over there and the toy has been placed
over and over again an a all right so he
gets at a not b air he has the action
and even though he sees the toys placed
there it's covered up he's looking where
the toy is when it's time to reach he
goes to this well so this is the 8th of
the error a part of his mind that guides
action is stuck and guides the what he
reaches for right but obviously another
part of his mind knows perfectly well
where the toy is right so it's not as if
it's all of one or all of the other his
mind is representing that there's a toy
down there
but the part of his brain or mind that
guides his action is still stuck at this
early developmental stages if he were to
ages right one guiding where his eyes
goes and one guiding the ultimate action
of or his hands goes and as he gets a
little older his eyes and hands will go
in the same place okay
last couple of things about how infants
are mathematicians because of course we
focused on language or social thought
but you know the ideas of counting and
ultimately arithmetic or math also come
out of a children's minds and the very
clever experiment and I'll show you two
of them that shows even at six months
infants are starting to prepare
themselves to become mathematicians and
here's how they begin the counting
they're shown this place of three
objects or two objects and then they
hear two sounds like boom boom and where
do they look they tend to look at the
one with two objects so this is pretty
impressive they're counting the two
they're relating something and sound to
something in sight that's arbitrarily
related but it shares the numerosity
right and if they get boom boom boom
three boom sounds then they go okay now
I like to display with three things they
understand in some level tunas and three
nos and so you start to have the basis
of having numbers and not only that
Karen Wynn at Yale has shown quite
cleverly not only do infants have
numbers they can do a little bit of
subtraction in addition so here's the
experiment she does she places an object
in a case the screen comes up now comes
a second object and the hand leaves okay
the screen drops and there are two one
plus one equals two and the infant is
okay no big deal but the screen drops
and there's one the infant to startle
that looks longer and they can do it the
other way around they can do subtraction
as well okay so they you know one plus
one equals two and if there's one left
by the trickery of the kind you saw
earlier they're disturbed that the
addition is not occurred correctly or
the subtraction is not occurred
correctly and there's kind of a debate
this is less lied about and here's the
core idea though the which is this that
our minds afford us by evolution
counting up to about four objects in the
world and many animals do that as well
that's sort of you know has to develop a
little bit but we have a lot running in
us so that the infants can do because of
course if you show seven if you give 77
booms they don't look for the display
with 77 versus 78 okay or they can't do
that
okay so they can operate in the world of
one two three or one two four and then
they discovered there's been a series of
studies in tribes that are relatively
isolated in different parts of the world
where they had in their language they
only have words for one two and three
and everything after that is really
described as many or a whole lot they
don't have words for five and up there's
no word in their language okay because
they've never needed it apparently okay
in the world they live in so they go to
them and they have them do little
counting tasks and as soon as they get
beyond about four they get very
inaccurate it's as if the mind naturally
can represent about four things in the
object world four things in the counting
world maybe because of that and after
that everything is a cultural invention
of higher level mathematics it builds
off one to four but you don't have it
unless your culture teaches it to you or
your culture invents it so and there's
been brain imaging studies too
suggesting that counting one two four is
very different in the brain then exact
mathematics beyond the number four or
five that's all culturally learned and
invented builds based on a certain
innate one to four capacity